foreign
by the way folks Washington Post is
reporting Fidelity uh the mutual fund
family is saying that 401k millionaire
Club grew thanks to a stock market rally
um George read over this this is good
this is pretty wild so new data from
Fidelity found the number of employees
with 401k balances over 1 million
dollars spiked 26 percent in the second
quarter so now there's 378 000 of those
accounts compared to under 300 000 by
the end of 2022 and the average balance
in these 401ks was 1.5 million dollars
and here's the key they stuck to it
these are people who contributed
steadily to their plans even when the
stock market took a heart clutching dive
it says they've seen that payoff in
their account balances and this is
something that you know we've been
preaching to you've been preaching it
for 30 years now but just stay on the
roller coaster and you won't get hurt
well and here's the thing you know when
the news reports that the stock market
is up
never
did you guys know the stock market's up
since the first of the year 15 percent
if you put in ten thousand dollars or
five thousand dollars or a thousand
dollars 500 million whatever at the
first of the year you would have made 15
on your money in an S P 500 which is a
stock market index right it's measuring
the growth of the stock market
and made 15 on your money but you know
the news is inflation's 9.6 there's
supply chain problems and Hillary the
hurricane not the woman hit California
I mean this is it that's a good caveat
yeah we need to be hurricane no emails
were deleted in this message but yeah so
the um wow I mean this is 15 in one year
you know from the first January 1 to
today have you heard a single news
report telling you this well I got to
give it to the Washington Post Fidelity
reporting millionaire Club is up right
the number of workers with a million
dollars or more in their 401ks hit an
all-time high wow and the eeyors are
still out there Dave you know what the
new line is now well a million dollars
isn't enough anymore Dave it's more than
you got Winer
that one's my favorite won't get you as
far as it used to it won't it'll get you
further than you are
but these people aren't retire whining
and they've got 1.5 million they're
still on the journey yeah and here's
what the interesting thing is you run
all these
formulas and theories and stuff I was
meeting with the every dollar team the
other day and they're working on a a
formula for a retirement calculator
we're going to build into that thing and
uh I was just just don't do it like the
financial industry because the financial
industry runs a bunch of hypothetical
crap that never actually occurs
what actually really occurs see if all
if I give you some examples I can say
for example okay if you invest a hundred
dollars a month from age 25 to age 65 in
a decent growth stock mutual fund that
average 12 percent you'd have one
million 172 000. that's an example
well a million 172 000 is not enough and
you didn't inflation adjust that and and
and you know is that CGR what kind of
what kind of freaking nerd cares you got
a million dollars more than your dad
who had nothing
shut your butt up and save money hello
this is the point so quit trying to our
purpose here is to get you to actually
do this stuff not run theoretical think
tanks
the doing it is the pit difference you
know most the people we interviewed that
made me Had a Million Dollars they they
can't tell you what a CGR is they didn't
sit and ring their little nerd
analytical hands over whether oh do we
what kind of inflation rate do we use
because in the last 10 years prior to
Biden it was 2.6 percent do we use a
post Biden inflation rate or pre-bidden
inflation rate or do we go back 72 years
since the CPI started and it's 4.2
percent what do we do with our good God
you sound just would you just shut up
and put some money in your account you
haven't even mentioned expense ratios
yet Dave I left those out too and 12 B1
fees like I don't know they're there
because I don't care if they're there
well the people that invest are the ones
that have money the ones that don't
invest because they get paralysis of the
freaking analysis don't do anything they
have no money
so that's the beauty of this young man
Brent oh yeah see he didn't need him
he's working on a boat
he's working on a boat in Maine hello
making thirty thousand he's going to be
a multi-millionaire because George told
him how to do it and he's gonna actually
go do it and he's not trying to impress
his friends with a giant car payment
well and
he didn't he didn't need some kind of
hypothetical
you know 19 variable adjusted
rationalization
to learn to be an investor he thought
you know my dad got me started with this
it's probably a good idea that I do some
more of it well way to go Brent you got
something called common sense they got
it in Maine they got it in Tennessee and
they got it in a few of the other states
out there you can look around you'll
find them get you some oh my gosh but
the study found that the average
investor in this millionaire study they
were just average they weren't prodigies
they weren't doing anything fancy and I
guarantee you they don't even know what
a 12 B1 fee is and this article ends
with this the majority of Savers stayed
the course and did not make significant
changes to the retirement savings Oh you
mean they didn't time the market
you mean they didn't worry about the
dollar being sniper shot by a new
whole new currency coming out of China
and Brazil we're all going to hell I'm
kicking my money out right now no they
just kept investing just merrily alone
stop naturally merrily merrily along